oh yeah that's right the Han Solo movie
comes out and a little over a month and
now we have a new trailer for the fact
that my Twitter wasn't lit up with a
bunch of people like dude you saw the
trailer talked about it in a video shows
that one not a lot of people know about
a new trailer or two people really don't
give a [ __ ] but I actually like this
trailer more than I like the teaser
trailer gives me new goggles to look at
as I want to talk about do we at least
first talk about the fact that might not
be the Millennium Falcon I mean it
tweeted this or set it in a video and
don't really remember at this point I
don't remember everything I say but it
has crossed my mind that maybe that's
not the Millennium Falcon in this movie
Millennium Falcon looks like a hamburger
with a bite out of the middle of it it
has that gap in the middle this one
doesn't have that gap I do think it is
the Millennium Falcon because it would
be too much for there to be another ship
that looks like the Millennium Falcon in
this movie in which case Lando is going
to get another ship that looks like this
[ __ ] but like a shittier version of this
ship and then he loses that ship to Han
Solo in a bet so it just looks like the
Millennium Falcon's a little more souped
up a little more new and it's gonna lose
the entire front of it what is it looks
different but they really do play up the
fact this is the Wild West vibe in the
Star Wars universe really the song in
the trailer doesn't sound like a Star
Wars song at all I mean there is a bit
of a hint of Star Wars in there later on
but for the most part is that down down
down perfect for that Western shot on a
gun holster at the hip that's not enough
here you go here's another shot from
behind with a holster on the hip because
it is a smuggler story in which case Han
Solo gets wrapped up in this world but
it doesn't look like he was in the
smuggling world before it's not like
we're seeing this Green smuggler it
looks like the fact that he's just a
dude who's a driver and a flyer who's
not a smuggler
Woody Harrelson even says I actually
think he's a really good line in the
trailer what do you Harrelson says
something like when you're in this life
you're in this life for good really
shows this is the part where this is the
course where Han Solo's life takes a
deviation and he becomes something else
it looks like they do a smuggling job
from a train which gets Malcolm Reynolds
like that's place alden ehrenreich being
hung so I don't think I'm personally
gonna be sold on him until I say the
movie if he pulls it off in the movie
great it's literally a lifetime of
someone else doing the role now there's
someone else in terms of nostalgia and
human evolution I'm not there yet I
guess I don't blame human nature on that
one to my genetic code can't fight it
but I did like when he looks at
Chewbacca for confirmation to is like
and he's like what do you think Donald
Glover as Lando totally sold on him
everything you've heard about me is true
I can't even say it like him because
he's so [ __ ] smooth I did think the
Droid sounded like Gwendoline Christie
I know it's not but it totally sounded
like phasma
which means gonna be a hundred theories
out there like captain phasma's actually
had the AI from the droid put in the
butt is where we never see your face
just cyborg again I know it's not put
down the keyboard did sound like her
though right like I'm not making that
[ __ ] I'll be to see Chewbacca's families
did you bug his wife she's not gonna
live there's no way to block is gonna
leave his wife to hang out with that
sausage fest unless something happens to
his wife I don't see that's a tragedy is
cinema right there put that live shot
holy [ __ ] oh my god hope Chewbacca's
gonna be okay
here's a sneak peek from the next movie
he's fine you ready for the Saturday
morning cartoon intro maybe he's just
from a TV show I'm just saying
well Han Solo and his crew survived tune
in next week same time same channel for
Hong solo I hope that one line for Han
Solo says I have a very good feeling
about this I hope it's just a nod and
that's it I don't want him to walk out
of a shitty situation after having that
good feeling being luck I will never
have a good feeling about anything ever
again in fact I will always have a bad
feeling about this we don't need to make
a bang because the knot is fine I hope
it stays a nod doesn't in this trailer
it made me reach your resolve I'm not
going into this movie looking for some
sort of epic Star Wars movie I'm not
expansion of lore I'm not going into
this movie to somehow relive my
childhood I have that [ __ ] at home what
I'm doing is I'm going into this movie
to possibly see a fun space smuggling
movie my personal apprehension comes
from my personal bias of the fact that I
really love Han Solo
I grew up on the old trilogy and I don't
necessarily want to see someone take on
that role I know that's just kind of a
[ __ ] thing in my own head there's
really nothing in this trailer that
makes me think hey that looks like [ __ ]
so in a world where I wanted to this
trailer to at least show me that this
movie could be fun the trailer makes the
movie look pretty damn fun right so the
new trailers a solo a Star Wars story
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]